he kind of became this sort of kind of a
mentor kind of a hero to me in a way Jai
Courtney opens up about his friendship
with late Spartacus co-star Andy
Whitfield not only in what he was
achieving within the world of our
profession but just in the way he lived
his life as well and we just became you
know fast friends and I just looked up
to him so much you know Andy's battle
with non-hodgkins lymphoma and ultimate
passing is documented in the film be
here now out April 8th I think I'm just
so numb from too much information it's a
weird thing to hear like you know
someone so young and so healthy um
certainly on the surface and so close to
you was a strength thing to kind of
digest but um you know at that time it
was never you know we're really like
considering the worst what do you want
people to know about Andy I don't know I
mean I think some of this is probably
clear in the film I mean he was often
cast as this very kind of strong
handsome sort of stoic type but Andy was
like he was a cheeky prick and like very
very very funny dude you know he
inspired people every day and engage
with people every day in a way that was
really quite you know magnetic and and
hard to sort of dispute or deny he
really did have the power to sort of
change lives in my heart I am convinced
that
this is all meant to be how do you think
he managed to stay so positive
throughout the entire thing I don't know
you know that's something that I was
always in awe of when he was with us and
uh and I still AM and it's pretty
amazing thing to be to see sort of kept
alive in the movie and a lot of what's
behind the title itself and and that
idea of be here now being present being
in that moment is that you know
circumstances are going to come at you
whether you like it or not and you know
they're going to happen you know they're
going to unfold one way or the other you
know and whether you think you have a
choice in how that works out or not
doesn't really matter but you're going
to have to deal with them so you know
accept them be present in the moment
that you're you know dealing with and be
true that be honest about it
you